wir alle wissen ja wie schwierig und es
manchmal ist sich aufzuraffen und sport
zu machen aber wie schwierig muss es
sein mit 70 und kräftig übergewichtig
sich aufzuraffen und tatsächlich sein
leben zu verändern eine frau hat auf
bewundernde art und weise das geschafft
sie ist als fitness oma bekannt in der
ganzen welt wir haben sie besucht
johann mcdonald aus ontario und kanada
73 jahre alt eine leidenschaftliche
gewichtheberin als fitness oma wurde sie
weltberühmt knapp 900 tausend follower
bei instagram dort zeigt fitness oma
joanne regelmäßig ihre
trainingseinheiten nun sprach die
fitness oma mit bild darüber wie wie im
hohen alter plötzlich zum gewichte heben
kam
ich war wirklich unglücklich ich wollte
schon einfach nicht zu enden wie meine
mama deren gesundheit sich immer weiter
verschlechtert hatte dabei muss man doch
beweglich bleiben mobil bleiben also
fing macdonald an zu trainieren und sie
startete eine strenge diät zählte
kalorien kohlenhydrate und eiweiß so
nahm sie 30 kilo ab von der
übergewichtigen gemütlichen großmutter
zur fitness oma ich will nicht schnell
gewicht verlieren sondern ich will es
für immer los werden und das wichtigste
plötzlich konnte joanne auch auf ihre
medikamente verzichten weg mit dem
blutdruck pillen weg mit den pillen für
die nieren und das glaubt kann jeder
auch im hohen alter
aber sie brauchen unterstützung ihr
braucht jemanden der euch dabei hilft
und wenn ihr leute um euch herum habt
die nein sager sind dann sind das die
falschen die braucht ihr nicht sie sind
gift für euer leben aber wir sind bild
und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren